foreign
so the big question that's coming up
with copyright is whether that fair use
for scraping kind of taking little bits
of information off of everyone's
websites can that scrape be used for
training these AI models
I am a lecturer at the University of
Texas here in Austin I teach in the Fine
Arts side of things teaching a lot of
game development classes everything from
programming to design but I also teach
quite a few classes on AI but I also run
my own game company I've been doing that
for about 12 years and as part of that
role I've been experimenting with AI and
machine learning since about 2015 to
2017.
thank you
their use in the US is a doctor and that
essentially permits some limited use of
copyright Beyond kind of the original
intent of copyright law fair use in
general is attempting to adapt to the
the digital age right we're talking
about laws that have existed for
hundreds of years and how we apply them
today is pretty challenging the real
question that I think we're going to see
quite commonly is whether the amount and
substance matters so there's this term
that the Minimus effect defense which is
saying we use so little of it we use
such a small piece that we're not really
impeding on the copyright only because
it was such a small element right and
the concept that the AI model creation
tools has is that it's using such a
small set piece such a small amount
of billions of images so if it's using
only a little bit of many many images is
it impeding on each one's copyright or
by using such small samples from each
one is it actually kind of passing
through that deep minerals so I believe
personally that's where we're going to
see the defense go and that's kind of
where we're going to see the the
copyright law and arguments come
from my perspective the question of
whether you know whether these tools
should use copyrighted materials should
they be scraped I'm of the belief that
they could and they should but the
output that comes from them should not
be copyrightable itself and that is of
my personal opinion is that if you use a
tool that creates images that came from
a five gigabyte or 100 terabyte scrape
of 5 billion images off the internet and
you make something new from it I don't
think you should be able to copyright
that image itself so in 2022 China
announced that any content made with AI
image tools text tools any media needs
to be watermarked right it needs a clear
label that says this was made with AI
China was the first major country to do
this right where we in the US are kind
of discussing it the European Union some
other locations are considering this
option and I personally think it's a
very smart idea
saying hey like you want to do AI stuff
you want to post it on the internet just
make sure that somewhere it's it's
recognized as such a great example of
this a couple weeks ago there was an
image that was going around the internet
of the Pope in like a very large coat a
puffer coat uh the the puffer Pope as I
like to call it and it spread the
internet quickly because it looks so
realistic people thought oh wow look at
the pope wearing kind of a new outfit
that's so cool and it took longer for
the information to get out but that was
AI generated than it took for the image
to spread initially so it's one of those
things that like bad news travels fast
right the AI content can spread faster
than a warning label behind it it's the
idea that the warning label is attached
to it I think it's a relatively smart
move
now the hard part is enforcing that
right how do you prevent someone from
scrubbing that away how do you prevent
someone from just kind of cutting a bit
of the image off the similar way that
you would see with like a credit to a
photographer and it's very hard to run
Force there are some solutions where it
sort of embeds the information in an
image or you know in the kind of GPT
style text there's like subtle hints
that it was made by the AI but there's a
very hard to enforce they're hard to
prove
and so I think it's a good idea in in
practice ideally it should work but
realistically Bad actors who would want
to get around it will find a ways around
that Watermark so I don't I think it's a
good first step but I don't think it is
the solution we need long term so in the
question of whether we in the United
States should kind of follow on to the
way China is handling this with their
water Marketing System I think that the
U.S due to our different rules of
copyright that the way we handle kind of
our our fair use and our freedom of
expression is different from China's
requiring a watermark on content made
with AI tools I think will be harder to
achieve in the U.S than it would be in
China China already has a lot of
structure for what is allowed on the
internet within China we don't all right
we're very open you know there's very
few limitations to what we can do online
and so for us to enforce it would be a
lot more difficult I don't think it
would be a bad move for us to attempt to
do so I just don't think with our
form of capitalism
we will succeed I there's very little
that we can do quickly enough to enforce
this law in the US